let's bring our panel in Jonah Goldberg
is the senior editor at the National
Review Mara liason national political
correspondent from National Public Radio
and Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist how important do you think
this finding is Jen I don't think it's
that important I think that we kind of
knew that there if there was if there
was real evidence of collusion we would
have heard about it by now there's been
so much journalistic exploration of this
there in so many committees something
would elite I think in many ways that
this is just simply going to be factored
into the noise on both sides the
Democrats you know are already coming
out saying that it was called off early
I'm sure Donald Trump is going to say
that this is proof that there was no
collusion and surprise that's taken this
long and so I think that it's just you
know the real I think the whole ballgame
depends on what the Miller investigation
finds one way or the other and I'll
still be surprised if they find cool
I asked Conaway this question did is
there any reason to expect that Muller
could find something different than the
committee found well he might but I
think there are some important things in
here there are things that both parties
could applaud number one there was
interference
number two we're not doing enough to
protect ourselves from the next round of
it and election system should be
hardened against it and you know this is
a pattern of Russian attacks that have
occurred now that is something that's
widely held and it's a good place to
start when the House Intelligence aside
the House Intelligence Committee has
actually been focused on Russia longer
than most people they were worried about
Russia long before it became something
in the headlines so when this committee
comes out with something about Russia
you should take it seriously and it is
interesting that they're talking about
recommendations for what to do for
elections I mean we have an election
coming up this week we've had elections
recently people need advice people need
guidance on how to make sure that their
election systems are properly taken care
of
it's also worth though taking a step
back and thinking about the larger
narratives that we've seen here we have
been subjected to over a year of a
Russia collusion theory that Trump and
was a traitor who is colluding with
Russia we have no evidence from the
committee and they have been looking at
it quite a lot and then we also have
this issue of the criminal leaks that
we've seen from Obama officials and
other highly placed intelligence
officials and they give some indication
that we'll get a little bit of
information on that now they're not in
the best position to prosecute the
criminal leaks that we have seen that we
know exists because we read about them
in the paper but that's something that's
going to need to continue to take place
even as States and other groups start
working on their electoral systems by
the way no tweet from Donald Trump on
this yeah the president hasn't yet
weighed in there were obviously
complaints from Democrats
Jona that this got wrapped up too
quickly you will remember a little less
than a year ago there was the
controversy over Devon Nunez who was the
chairman who had an ethics complaint
filed against him he stepped aside to
let Conaway take over the way that
Conaway handle it he was cleared on the
ethics investigation the way that
Conaway has comported himself does it
leave him less open to criticism than he
possibly might have been it might we are
in such a hyper partisan moment there's
gonna be criticism no matter what on all
sides and look I agree with Molly they
should be taken this should be taken
seriously but part of the problem here
with the exception where it says that
they didn't they broke with the
intelligence community's assessment
about the Russians wanting to have a
preference for Trump which I think the
rush they just thought they were
generally trying to sow chaos I think
they were until they thought Trump could
actually win and then they lean that way
I don't think it was a big difference
because when you actually look at what
the tweets and social media were they
were more pathetic than you know
overpowering but almost all of this is
the the general Washington Consensus at
this point right we are still in the
midst of this complete Russia hysteria
it is true that like Saturday Night Live
you're making fun of the idea that
there's a big treasonous collusion but
we still have a special prosecutor in
dealing with all this even though it was
any of that not true about this one
thing is that we know everybody except
the present United States as admitted
and says that the pressure interfered
and it messed with our elections right
but what is also being said is that
Trump is a traitor who is not part of
the consensus
I think that people should be on record
if they don't think that's true they
should say that that's not true because
that's actually what a lot of people
have been hearing for over a year that's
nothing that is no every what anything I
said there's a bigger national security
issue that if you listen to the
president it's not important and it
didn't happen this says Russia
intervened they tried to sow discord
they're going to be at it again that's
pretty important but the reason why
President Trump is talking about that is
because people have used this story for
partisan political ends talking about I
think that what most people see when
they see the media coverage of this is
that people have tried to use this to D
legitimize the president and that this
has been part of a pattern of behavior
by intelligence officials and people in
the media to create a lot of angst over
this story precisely to deliver to my
senses of his entire cabinet of his
entire national security establishment
well Donald Trump has also said that
there was I'm gonna call the buzzer in
this for because we do want to get on to
the the school violence policy that the
school safety policy that the White
House came out with yesterday everything
that he's been talking about except
raising the age for buying a long gun
the president's waiting on age 18 to 18
to 21 age limits watching court cases at
ruling before acting States are making
this decision
things are moving rapidly on this but
not much political support to put it
mildly Molly is he backing down in the
face of enormous opposition from the NRA
well yes and that's good I mean when he
was speaking last week he was saying
that due process didn't matter for
taking away people's guns he was talking
about age limits for people for young
people for buying rifles those are not
popular ideas and those are things that
would he would get a lot of pushback in
the state of Florida yeah in the state
of Florida which is a pretty pro-gun
state I think that when you look at
polls about the age limit eighty-seven
percent seventy two percent Rasmussen
which was the lowest poll I could find
had 67 percent supporting raising the
age limit this is the same age limit for
handguns so I think there is lots of
public support the president's right
there's not a lot of political support
among Republicans in Congress that's
true right this does it look like it
came Jenner because the NRA came out and
very loudly was against this
advertisements
it depends on your level of hostility
here right I mean I don't think he
necessarily caved because he says things
in these meetings that he then walks
back all of the time but the actual
things that they're proposing I think
they all make sense they're good I mean
I think some of them the Knicks fix
thing is they're basically saying now we
really mean it that government officials
are supposed to uphold the law okay
incentives to follow the law yeah might
as well yeah in their pathetic and look
this is better than nothing and every
Democrat will say the same thing is it
isn't it ironic